what has changed at heathrow this
morning well a plethora of airlines are
taking immediate action tom is quite
amazing they're moving ahead of the
regulators and taking a leaf out of
American Airlines American regulators
books and saying now you must have two
people in the cockpit at all times now
we know that regulators are already
discussing Civil Aviation Authority here
in the UK is chatting with a european
regulator the german regulator is
discussing with their own airlines but
ahead of the game we've already had
easyjet you've had monarch Virgin
Atlantic thomas cook so UK players
already imposing new rules vary from
today that two people must be in the
carpet canada ahead of the game as well
i want a conversation here with caroline
hide and brendan greeley because they
have lived on these airplanes in Europe
Caroline let me start with you quickly
the idea here of how the conversation
will go this weekend you leave Bloomberg
you have your own life on the weekends
how will people frame this tragedy in
London with nervousness and with soul
searching I think Tom you've got to ask
yourself what our airline is doing when
it comes to assessing the pilots what
sort of focus are they giving to their
state of mental health we understand in
the German press they are now diecut
Deeping the digging deep into the
personal life of the copilot andreas
Lubitz asking themselves whether he had
proper personal problems with his
girlfriend is that what drove him there
was remarkable event and I think
soul-searching has to be done as to what
airlines are doing about that Carolyn
let me jump in here the German press has
been way out ahead of this this morning
both Spiegel and build have evidence
both from the prosecutor's office in
Bissell Dorf and from acquaintances of
andreas Lubitz that it was a little bit
more than an argument with his
girlfriend that he had in fact you know
was being either handled or there's some
evidence of some psychological real
problems is that do we have any
confirmation of that in Bloomberg known
as yet but we do know that they're also
looking reports from the German press
have been looking into his history with
lufthansa actually while he was training
it seems they had to take periods of
time out because he was suffering from
depression this is what the German
newspapers are reporting and
only questions have to be asked of
Germanwings parent company deutsche
lufthansa were they really assessing the
mental health of this man and as to
whether he should have been in charge of
a plane and at that time of course
European regulators are not imposing
that you have two people in the cockpit
at one time